in some states here in germany the new
school year has begun and with a return
to classroom instruction
the government is pushing for children
over 12 to get vaccinated against covet
19.
it's a controversial appeal because the
country's vaccine authority
hasn't yet recommended the jobs for 12
to 17 year olds
this 12 year old is finally getting a
shot
accompanied by his parents he's getting
vaccinated at the end of his school
holidays
just before heading back to the
classroom so
far only about one in five young people
have had their first job in germany
the health ministry wants to change that
by making the process
much easier
enough vaccine doses and there are two
different types of vaccines that have
been approved for this age group
biontech pfizer and moderna in light of
this we're confident
in our next step
germany's vaccine authority has not yet
recommended immunizing 12 to 17 year
olds
however many health experts have long
pointed to international studies
which highlight the benefits
so overwhelmingly in favor of immunizing
children
and it would be an absolute tragedy if
the delta variant got into the
classrooms
it's time to move ahead even without the
official recommendations
the vaccine authority says there's still
not enough data
it says it's working as quickly as it
can but it also points to another issue
this whole discussion is ignoring the
real problem which is getting all
of the 18 to 59 year old age group fully
immunized
this will actually be the real deciding
factor of the so-called
fourth wave
also some foreign news for at-risk
groups
from september on they will be able to
get a booster shot
and those who had either the astrazeneca
or johnson
johnson vaccines will also be eligible
for a shot with an mrna vaccine
for more on this i'm now joined by ntw
chief political correspondent melinda
crane
and melinda as we heard germany is going
to be offering booster shots for people
considered at
risk is that expected to help the
country stop a possible
fourth wave of infections
certainly that's the hope in fact
infection rates have been creeping up
here in germany uh
for recent weeks so these booster shots
are designed to protect those with
vulnerable immune systems
those who despite vaccination would be
most susceptible to what's called a
breakthrough infection
especially with the very contagious
delta
variant of covid so the is the intention
here is not only to protect
these vulnerable people but also to
ensure that the country's health systems
don't become overburdened the german
government is
apparently not sidestepping the
country's vaccine commission but pushing
vaccinations
for youngsters at 12 and older how are
people reacting to that
so far there hasn't been that much
reaction and
until now many parents and even
pediatricians
have been somewhat hesitant about uh
vaccinating younger people
just 20 percent of germany's 12 to 19
year olds have gotten the job so far
so the fact is much of the pressure to
get young people vaccinated is actually
coming from politicians
and they're reacting to two things first
of all schools are reopening as you said
and parents are anxious and frustrated
that not enough has been done to reduce
overall risks in the schools and avoid
renewed
school closures secondly the country
and the politicians in particular are
facing a dilemma about how to overcome
an overall lag
in the vaccination campaign in general
other countries are talking about making
vaccination mandatory
but even incentives to get the job are
problematic problematic here in germany
due to this country's nazi era history
of medical abuses
politicians don't want to be seen as
compelling citizens to submit to a
medical procedure
so in a sense to avoid and sidestep
that dilemma i think there's a certain
degree of
actionism here in regard to getting
young people vaccinated
melinda crane there thank you very much